ouais j'accueille maintenant jean marc
morandini
jean bart
bonsoir daniel hechter nicola sirkis
d'indochine qu'on ne présente plus jean
marc morandini alors tout le monde parle
de votre émission consacrée à la
télévision sur europe 1 et à l'âge de 38
ans jean marc morandini vous effectué un
come back réussi comme rédacteur en chef
et comme journaliste alors votre
émission c'est tous les jours de 10h30 à
12h sur europe 1 vous avez été le
premier à parler de la télévision à la
radio puisque avant j'étais on parlait
jamais de télévision la radio parce que
ça veut dire que les gens le soir
n'avait pas écouté la radio qu'ils
avaient regardé la télévision
et puis vous êtes arrivé vous avez mis
tout le monde d'accord et au
garde-à-vous d'ailleurs et tout le monde
écoute désormais parce qu'après vous il
y en a eu d'autres souvent des coûts des
émissions sur la télévision le matin à
la radio voix là et vous publiée à
l'archipel un livre intitulé le bal des
faux culs
télé radio ce qu'on ne vous dis pas
alors je veux dire la quatrième de
couverture parce que beaucoup de choses
sont dites
lorsque je suis arrivée à paris je
croyais les sourires sincères et les
compliments honnête
naïvement je me suis jeté dans la fosse
aux lions j'ai animé une émission sur
tf1
la presse a jugé j'ai été plus souvent
trahi qu'aimer et j'en ai pris plein la
gueule je pensais que l'audience
justifier tout à tort j'ai payé mon
erreur j'ai souffert mais j'ai appris à
dire non et je le redirai s'il le faut
tordeur
la prime a glissé une sorte de jean
moulin dit pas exactement alors le livre
de jean marc morandini peuvent se
résumer de la façon suivante
c'est là comme à gauche et ça c'est la
première partie après
et après
n'empêche qu'à la lecture de votre livre
votre mère a pleuré pendant deux jours
elle ne soupçonnait pas dites vous le
calvaire que vous aviez vécu à l'époque
oui parce que j'aimais pas en parler à
ce moment là en fait je suis assez
solitaire donc je m'étais vraiment
replier sur moi même et je parlais pas
de ces moments assez difficiles qui
était de lire la presse chaque matin et
qui était de s'en prendre plein la
gueule dont je préfèrerais avoir une
forme d'auto destruction
c'est à dire me renfermer sur moi même
mangé j'ai pris 15 kilos à ce moment là
j'ai foncé au nutella
ouais c'est vrai ça paraît qu'on va dire
comme ça c'est vrai vous avez vécu ça
aussi non il ya un moment les critiques
étaient terribles avec vous nos wii et
c'est on a sans doute mieux vécu dans le
sens que la rencontre avec le public et
appartements ont fait un concert et
qu'on voit que les gens aiment toujours
ce qu'on fait c'est beaucoup moins sans
doute douloureuse à un groupe aussi
important ça c'est à dire que oui nous
sommes aussi vive énormément de gens ce
donc sa bio thaïs et impalpable
alors quand vous écrivez ils ont failli
me tuer c'est pour ne pas avoir à
évoquer certains de vos actes désespérés
c'est ce genre de ceux dont j'ai pas
très envie de parler parce que justement
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit donc voilà
je crois que l'écriture se suffit il n'y
a pas besoin d'en rajouter j'ai pas
envie de faire pleurer dans les
chaumières peut être on peut demander à
ta maman de couper son poste ça s'est su
sauver avant la vie de maman couple
poste à chercher une bière non mais bon
il ya eu des moments très très dur
comment est ce qu'à un moment bon voilà
est-ce qu'à un moment vous êtes vous
avez envie je sais que vous avez envie
de vous exiler médicaments vous êtes
vraiment eu envie d'en finir
j'ai écrit un bouquin j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à dire à vous le dites pas
justement peut-être parce que j'ai pas
envie de le dire voilà on va prendre les
choses de zéro si tu veux bien laurent
ou alors que repose la question
peut-être sert vraiment de faiblesses il
pourra obtenir une réponse
on va prendre les choses de zéro donc en
fait votre vocation journalistique est
venue très tôt et je conseille pas
concernant jean marc morandini c'est
qu'en fait tout le monde l'a connu dans
tout est possible mais qu'en fait vous
étiez le journaliste avant de faire
cette émission ça a commencé très tôt
malgré l'opposition de vos parents et
finalement votre mère merci maman encore
et encore héroïne de ceux-ci sa soirée
elle a fini par vous inscrire à l'école
de journalisme
de marseille pour elle c'était pas un
métier elle me disait toujours
journaliste c'est pas un métier qu'est
ce que tu vas aller faire dans ce monde
là voilà c'est un métier d'apparence et
c'est vrai que moi j'avais vraiment
envie de faire ça je crois que déjà en
fête au fond d'elle elle pensait que
c'était un métier de faux cul donc est
peut-être devant c'est que j'avais dit
qu'on présente également sa n'avait pas
tord dit non mais c'est vrai qu'elle
pensait que je serai pas bien dans cet
univers-là non mais ensuite vous faites
un premier stage au quotidien le
méridional et puis vous allez les faire
3 toulouse vous présenter le journal
télévisé à l'âge de 20 ans vous étiez le
plus jeune à l'époque oui j'étais plus
jeune présentateur de journal télévisé
c'est mon prof en fait qui était devenu
rédacteur en chef à toulouse et qui m'a
un jour propulsé comme ça devant l'écran
voilà c'est un vrai bonheur quoi vraie
joie c'était le rêve est la vôtre moment
elle y croyait à ce moment là n'ont
toujours pas mais j'y crois toujours pas
aujourd'hui de m'adapter très laid sur
la lune ensuite la 5 donc vous êtes
grand reporter à la 5 c'est votre la
meilleure époque de votre vie ça c'était
génial parce qu'on était une petite
équipe on se battait contre les grands
qui était tf1 et france 2 et puis on
devait construire une chaîne et donc je
raconte ça donc parce que le 8 avril
1995 quand pascale breugnot de tf1 vous
appelle vous êtes en fait un journaliste
il là vous faites tout est possible vous
souvenez tout est possible daniel non
vous souvenez pas toutes être au mieux
tant mieux
il est ravi tu t'en souviens nicolas oui
tout est possible ne savais pas
les anonymes qui viennent raconter leur
histoire d ordinaire du cud angoisses
des larmes quoi s'est installé cet
ancien de menus et c'était la recette
magique des 50% parts de marché c'est à
dire qu'on savait qu'il fallait mettre
ce dosage à l'antenne et ça marchait
tous les coups c'est un dosage magique
mais c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là tf1
disais c'est l'audience à tout prix
voilà c'était c'était une époque était
avant la quête de sens et avant
accueille deux sens hier plus d'un
moment ils se sont aperçus qu'à faire de
l'audience à tout prix m un problème
d'image non il me touche où il ya de
temps en temps pour faire propre quoi
exactement fait maintenant ils sont dans
un espèce d'équilibré c'est à dire il ya
à la fois bataille et fontaine ya là
beaucoup bu beaucoup bataille et
fontaine et de temps en temps nicolas
hulot s'était serait pas mal il ya les
liaisons dangereuses par exemple c'était
pas mal vont très bien ils font ils font
des choses bien aussi laisser trouver
cet équilibre entre
entre juste la recherche d'audience et
puis la quête de sens qui elle ne l'est
pas d'audience on le sait on vous a
proposé la star ac' bout ouais ouais et
alors non
les voilà donc un effectivement il ya
une émission le 29 décembre 93 qui fait
60 2% de parts de marché on a évidemment
tout le monde en live a été bon c'est
vrai j'en rêve fluo jean-louis assez
étonnamment j'arrive pour l'afflux d'une
émission c'était comme à 6 62% c'est
quoi les sujets les sujets c'était lolo
ferrari
c'était la première apparition à la
télévision de lolo ferrari seul mérite
voilà donc là on peut dire les choses il
est vendu votre âme au diable quoi oui
oui je suis rentré dans le système et
j'ai accepté les règles de ce système là
oui parce que votre personnalité et
complètement goût mais en fait à
l'antenne dire que dès que vous faites
petit peu d'humour où vous prenez un
petit peu de recul par rapport à ce que
vous présentez ces supprimés au montage
sont à peu près 5 heures
l'émission est resté une heure et demie
au final et c'est s était très réglée en
fait c'était vraiment il y avait des
règles très strictes mais c'était
questions-réponses questions réponses et
allez surtout pas sortir de ce schéma là
et vous dit à l'époque effectivement
c'est tout ce qu'on peut vous reprocher
toute façon vous dites je ne réfléchis
plus je me laisse porter circo labs a un
peu baissé les braves de un peu laissé
les choses aller à vous mais en fait je
me suis dit finalement j'arrive dans une
grande famille qu'est la famille tf1
c'est la première chaîne d'europe c'est
vrai donc ils savent ce qu'ils font
moi chaque fois que j'essayais de mettre
un peu de personnalité ça n'a pas marché
faut dire la vérité quand j'essayais de
mettre un côté plus journaliste à quand
vous faites le rwanda c'est un échec
je vous dis ton truc sur le rwanda ça
fait chier tout le monde aurait pu le
faire et c'est vrai ça fait 20 % à ce
moment là l'audience est tombée à 20%
quand je suis allé faire un sujet sur la
guerre au rwanda
ait chebib a oui doivent avoir raison si
ça fait 20 % ça veut dire que ça
n'intéresse pas le public
donc je veux dire qu'il faut pas faire
ça sur tf1 horaire en revanche quand
vous faites la fille qui sait inoculé le
sida par amour pour son compagnon ou le
nec a vendu ces deux mômes pour cent
mille bas j'ai dit stop
là j'ai dit stop bateau et je me suis
dit qu'on ne faisant pas à l'interview
en plateau forcément ils n'auraient rien
à diffuser il pourrait vous lanciez les
sujets que vous n'aviez même pas vu avec
ça c'est ça c'était surréaliste c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui je me demande
comment j'ai accepté ça mais encore une
fois c'est pour ça que je veux pas
mettre toute la faute sur tf1 parce que
moi aussi je pouvais dire non à ce
moment là je voulais dire non j'ai pas
envie de le faire mais
c'est vrai que je faisais un regard
caméra comme ça les gizeh et tout de
suite regardez ce reportage
je ne faisais comme ça les gens en plus
c'est pas tellement pour l'inculpation
c'est ce que vous gagnez à l'époque
c'est vraiment pas grand au début je
gagne au début la première édition
c'était gratos c'était pour voir et puis
ensuite je gagnais 2500 francs et puis
c'est monté tout petit fils aymon
terrasses de bars étaient pas énorme
c'était pas énorme mais non c'était
vraiment c'était ma passion gamin quoi
c'était faire de la télé j'avais envie
de faire ça vous avez le sentiment des
fois vous de vous laisser emporter par
le marketing le business
on sent très vite on peut pas laisser
super dur de dire non dans ces moments
dans fait quand on est dans une énorme
machine quand on est dans une chaîne où
on est propulsé en deuxième partie de
soirée confessions 3% de part de marché
c'est super dur à ce moment là de dire
non je m'en vais mais je m'en vais je
fais quoi
voilà c'était ça le vrai bien là votre
jeu baril fait jouer mais autre chose
mais quand on campus qui permet à cause
de cette émission on sait qu ailleurs on
trouvera rien à priori là la presse se
déchaîne
c'est ce qu'on appelle un lynchage
médiatique 8 les mots font mal ils
peuvent tuer qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit
de pire à ce moment là je crois que le
pire c'était vraiment quand on
m'insultait en tant que personne c'est à
dire que les journalistes choisis une
association très simple il disait ce mec
présenter l'émission merde donc
forcément c'est un con voilà et je pense
que personne n'est allé plus loin que ça
personne n'a cherché à savoir si
derrière vous il n'y avait pas pascale
breugnot et berlin bouquet oui et puis
qui j'étais vraiment c'est vrai que
enfin moi ça me fait gerber ces
journalistes qui écrivait sur moi qui
m'insultaient qui décrivait mon état
d'esprit alors que jamais je ne les
avais rencontrés
moi j'accepte qu'un mec qui me
rencontrent pendant une heure ou deux
heures à la fin du day j'ai dit ce mec
c'est un conte bon ok il s'est fait son
avis on a discuté ensemble mais c'est
vrai que le mec qui écrit juste parce
qu'il m'a vu à la télévision présenter
une émission
ce mec est un abruti comme l'a fait libé
a plusieurs reprises je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse a pas de sens il peut me
trouver mauvais présentateur mais ne pas
savoir si je suis con ou pas ouais non
mais à l'époque ce que terry fait que
vous continuez à défendre les missions 1
mais oui parce que je suis un bon petit
soldat mais les sens bien j'ai pas envie
de cracher dans la soirée vous continuez
à dire non non c'est vachement bien
c'est vachement bien je dis c'est pas du
voyeurisme
les retrouver il ya des gros moments
pathétiques suis d'accord mais on
obligeait défendre enfin quand on est
dans le bateau oui il faut défendre où
il faut partir et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là moi j'ai pas eu le courage de
partir donc je défends du mal à vous
défendiez est alors qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes d'accord avec les critiques vite
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il avait raison
ouais il avait raison c'est encore une
fois sur l'émission elle-même bien sûr
voilà alors là ça devient très grave
parce que bourg et d'antidépresseurs de
nutella n'a plus les antidépresseurs et
vous pensé un moment allez vous
installer à miami mais parce que je me
suis dit voilà sa fille ça fait quatre
ans que je fais cette émission sur tf1
aujourd'hui j'ai une image de merde donc
voilà enfin plus personne ne va me va
embaucher
donc la seule solution c'est partir et
je vais allez recommencer ma vie
ailleurs et elle n'a rien et là vous
êtes convoqué un d'armes
d'accord mon oncle à etienne mougeotte
c'est la première fois que vous le voyez
vous êtes là depuis quatre ans mais vous
a jamais reçus dans son bureau
ça c'est surprenant c'est vrai que j'ai
passé quatre ans à tf1 et pas une fois
j'ai vu ni etienne mougeotte ni patrick
le lay et patrick ollier alors j'ai
toujours pas rencontré j'aurais met
alors à ce moment là vous dites ce qui
est incroyable quand vous êtes convoqué
par mougeotte vous vous dites il va me
proposer d'intégrer la rédaction et oui
parce que j'avais un statut de
journaliste intérêts en fait sur ma
fiche de paye et j'avais un contrat où
il avait écrit journalistes donc je suis
dit il va peut-être me retirer d'antenne
euro mettent sur mon métier initial qui
était reporter pour par terre pour
partir à travers leur avait pris plein
la gueule parce qu'il dit d'abord tout
est possible s'arrête et deuxièmement et
vous dit tu es grillé donc tu va servir
de fusible en gros c'est pour ça il m'a
menti
qui va payer pour tout le monde il m'a
même dit que servi de paratonnerre
finalement dans cette affaire c'est à
dire que pendant quatre ans nous on a
fait nos émissions tranquille
toute la presse s'est acharné sur toi et
finalement on a pu faire des trucs à
côté et personne n'y fait attention
voilà c'est terrible ouais ouais c'est
enfin voila j'ai tourné la page j'ai pas
envie d'avoir d'aigreur non plus par
rapport à ça non mais bon voilà mais
c'est vrai que c'est ma naïveté enfin
c'est ce que je dis je n'arrête pas de
répéter ça mais c'est vrai parce que
c'est le gamin qui arrive de marseille
qui à un moment ce rêve de la télévision
se retrouvent propulsés sur tf1 en
deuxième partie de soirée et crois que
les gens sont là pour l'aider
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai compris que
c'était passé à la télé mais à ce moment
là je croyais encore qu'on pouvait avoir
des amis et des gens qui vous aident à
avancer aujourd'hui vous avez quand même
une grande méfiance envers les gens de
la télévision
et est-ce que c'est pas aussi ridicule
finalement dans un premier temps de se
méfier de personnes et dans un deuxième
temps de se méfier de tout le monde et
surtout pardon mais j'ai envie de
rajouter entre 2,9 et bardos et laquelle
qu'elle a le mieux vieilli non mais je
crois finalement que aujourd'hui la
confiance il faut la gagner il faut que
les gens la gagne en face de moi là et
ensuite vous remonter doucement à
travers la bande fm jusqu'à rmc
et aujourd'hui on va pas vous être
aidante et vous vous dites en fait la
télévision en rnt quand on arrête de
faire semblant
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de jouer à
un moment donné il faut être soi-même
dans le bilan vous dit ma grande faute
c'était de subir ouais ouais je crois
aujourd'hui je sais dire non qu'est ce
qui vous fait vibrer un vibromasseur
parallèle entre ce que vous avez subi
finalement est ce que subissent les
jeunes gens qui font des émissions de
télé réalité parce qu'en fait on profite
de rêve d'adolescent ils veulent être
les stars vouliez faire de la télé ça tu
peux la même chose finalement après on
les exploite
on les presse comme des citrons on les
jette comme des kleenex c'est un peu
pareil événement quasi jamais été un
héros de télé réalité avant l'heure
ouais c'est presque ça enfin c'est pour
ça que dans le bouquin moi j'ai voulu
décrypter aussi ce qu'était la télé
réalité d'aujourd'hui
lorsque je crois que c'est un peu la
même chose c'est à dire que on pense
connaître cet été là je crois que c'est
également aujourd'hui quand ils vont
dans la télé réalité ils pensent qu'ils
connaissent ce système
ouais en fait ils ne le connaissent pas
ils connaissent pas les coulisses et
finalement ils sont toujours perdants à
la fin ils se retrouvent toujours broyés
par ce système
ouais à la télé réalité vous êtes très
pessimiste jean marc morandini vous
dites bon mais ça c'est les jeux du
cirque tout le monde le sait mais un
jour il y aura un suicide quoi il faut
vraiment ce mois je pense qu'on est
souvent très dur avec ses gamins pour
faire du spectacle
ouais il ya plein d'émissions de
téléréalité où on voit les castings par
exemple et on traite ces gamins vraiment
comme comme un moins que rien en leur
balance à la figure que c'était mauvais
qu'ils ne réussiront jamais sur le mec
qui vient de la guadeloupe qu a pris
l'avion qui a attendu 10 heures dans le
froid et qu'on garde une minute on lui
disant qu'elle soit nuls mais même de la
banlieue parisienne fois parce qu'il ya
des gamins c'est l'espoir de sortir de
sortir du non lieu
ils se disent qu'ils vont réussir avec
ça et finalement on les balance que
comme comme vraiment des sous merdes
et tout ça pour faire rire finalement
parce qu à la fin on fait un montage qui
fait rire tout le monde se marre et le
lendemain c'est scénarisé c'est bien
celle-là rendu cette histoire quand même
alors vous dites en plus qu'aux états
unis on arrive à des trucs moi je
connaissais pas cette histoire vous en
parler c'est ont fait des autopsies
les authentiques autopsie en direct
c'est à dire qu'on ouvre le corps de
cadavre et que même à la limite
l'animateur il fouille dans l'estomac
pour savoir quel était le dernier repas
du mak adéquat en fait j'en mets ces
règles aujourd'hui si elles devaient
marcher 1,7 à part ça marchera plus ça
va ça marche le genre de truc ils ont
fait récemment ils ont fait par exemple
un batchelor nain aussi râle donc passé
c'est complètement surréaliste c'est
vraiment c'est du spectacle poussé à
l'extrême
mais on va y venir en france c'est
évident qu'on va y venir d'autres se
sont alors dans un an vous voyez de
nouveau à l'antenne jean marc morandini
peut-être en fait aujourd'hui moi j'ai
décidé que après mon aventure c'est plus
la télé qu'ils allaient me poser les
règles mais c'est moi qui allait tenter
d'imposer mes règles à la télé les
règles à moi c'est de faire une émission
en direct et d'être le patron du contenu
des missions mais c'est ça ou rien te
passer ça originaux sinon bien sinon
miami parce que ce qui fait savoir quand
même c'est que jean-marc rêve toujours
c'est fou dans dix ans des restaurateurs
ami ami avec avec plein d'enfants oui je
rêve de ça mais parce que c'est vrai
qu'en fait il ya une règle à la télé qui
est que j'explique dans le livre de
publicitaire qui est je lèche je lâche
gelin
ouais en fait ce sont les trois étapes
principe avec lelouch aussi mais non
mais ça allait pas en fait c'est pour ça
que je vais pas me c'est à dire qu'on
commence par être les ché ensuite on est
lâché et ensuite on est cloué au pilori
j'ai vécu ces trois étapes aujourd'hui
en train de revenir au début tu 3 fait
lécher voilà donc c'est pas désagréable
mais mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
voilà je suis revenu au début de ce
système là je sais que d'ici deux trois
ans quatre ans peut-être je serai lâcher
à nouveau mais j'attendrai pas d'être
lynché je partirai avant je m'arrêterai
à la deuxième et à nous simplement mais
n'ayez pas peur tout ira bien
we re ah bon jean marc morandini
entretien
jean marc en ligne pour vous permettre
de revenir au firmament du parc
je vous fais une dame ou faux culs
vous la trouvez comment la nouvelle
émission d'arthur à fabuleuse j'adore
arthur et puis en plus il ne me fais pas
de procès pour mon livre
bon donc c'est vraiment génial très bien
vous trouvez pas que la quête de sens de
tf1 a porté ses fruits finalement ah bah
oui oui tf1 pour moi c'est aujourd'hui
la chaîne de référence
vous pensez que la ferme rentrer dans
l'objectif louable d'apporter un regard
neuf sur le monde rural
oui puis je pense que c'est un vrai
palliatifs par rapport à ce que faisait
pivot sur france 2 bataille et fontaine
vous êtes un petit peu dur avec avec eux
dans votre livre
ils font quand même du bien aux gens ces
gens là mon avis ces gens là en fait
dispense l'amour et je prends je
regrette beaucoup ce que j'écris sur
cauet cette idée de mélanger les invités
cette idée d'avoir des interviews
thématique d'avoir des colonnes d'avoir
des rideaux c'est original non oui je
crois que vous avez pompé sur lui
d'ailleurs ouais bah oui j'aime inventer
celle qu il a tout inventé la simplicité
d'un stéphane bouillaud le présentateur
de l'île de la tentation ça vous oui ça
me touche d'autant plus que c'est
vraiment une star
ouais je crois que tout le monde l'a
imagine tout de suite et voient tout de
suite qui ses fans oui est ce que vous
arrivez jean-marc a raté un seul merci
pour l'info l'émission d'emmanuel chain
a jamais jamais promet des millions ont
regardé cette émission chaque soir
d'ailleurs comme moi j'adore carole
rousseau et vous ah bah oui moi moi je
rêve de passer un week-end avec assez
dommage que scrupule a été supprimé mais
non c'était là encore c'est vraiment une
émission de référence à oui et ça me
manque en fait ça donc je l'enregistré
je me repassais cassette chez moi
montiel montiel ses gammes avec subir
cultiver non